[Applaus]
ja da wir sitzen jetzt zwei ausgewiesene
sucht und drogen experten zum alten ist
dass boris quednau er ist der psychologe
und professor an der psychiatrischen
universitätsklinik zürich und erforscht
die wirkung unterschiedlicher drogen auf
geist und körper und daneben toni pertl
psychiater und präsident der
eidgenössischen kommission für
suchtfragen berät außerdem bundesrat
wenn es um politik geht herzlich
willkommen in beiden herbert ich möchte
mit ihnen beiden gleich über unseren
umgang sprechen aus gesellschaft den wir
haben mit drogen und rauschmittel davor
aber interessiert mich was sie zur
diskussion auf dem sofa denken
zu diesen trend drogen
leistungssteigernde substanzen micro-sim
wurde erwähnt daneben gibt es aber auch
dieses mdma das uns irgendwie empathisch
mach das partydroge und endlich
verbindung zu anderen menschen heraus
aus dieser einsamkeit dann gibt es
dieses alaska dass die leute in den
amazonas reisen und den sud einer wurzel
trinken und dann irgendwie sich mit der
natur wieder in verbindung führen
was sagt das alles über unsere zeit
verwertung wir haben vorher gehört dass
der konsum vom sicher tief in substanz
und auch eine kulturelle praxis ist und
kulturelle praxis verändern sich in der
heutigen zeit kommt das was sie geld was
ich erzählt habe unter einer seite haben
wir hier natürlich dafür substanz und
konsumieren die mehr leistung bringen
und auf der anderen seite haben wir ist
als die uns rasch entspannen lassen die
uns rasch in die freizeit so quasi
entlassen und die und ein drittes
element dass substanzen konsumiert die
microsys und marco russ im bereich wo es
eigentlich darum geht dass wir etwas
nehmen also nicht zu viel
also wir sind in der zeit wo es wo wir
also ein bisschen kaffee kaffee koffein
oder ratsam ohne sahne und und war
bereit sodass wir wären hier in dieser
beratung und haben wir eine multi eine
gesellschaft mit sehr vielen
unterschiedlichen aspekten die in chur
zur zeit erfüllt werden müssen da helfen
diese droge natürlich diese
befindlichkeiten die wir suchen schnedl
und rasch und häufig auch zielführend
zuzuhören ist philosophin svenja
flaßpöhler hat von einer perversion des
genießens gesprochen
ja ich glaube jede gesellschaft trägt
oder verdient die drogen die sie bekommt
und das problem ist glaube ich dass wir
immer das gefühl haben raus wäre etwas
universelles was es immer schon gegeben
hat und wir nicht wirklich unterscheiden
zwischen re kreativen rausch also genuss
rausch und dem rausch der in spirituelle
erfahrungen eingebettet ist es gibt
kultur vergleichende studien aus den
70ern die später tatsächlich nicht
weiter wiederholt wurden die gezeigt
haben ja stimmt bewusstseinserweiternde
oder bewusstseinsverändernde erfahrungen
gehören immer schon in unserer kultur
ist kultur historie viele völker viele
gesellschaften haben das betrieben aber
die allermeisten haben das immer im
rahmen spirituelle erfahrungen betrieben
und wenn man sich anschaut wie der
genuss rausch gesehen wurde dann ist das
allen meisten religion eine sünde
gewesen und deshalb glaube ich unser
verhältnis zum es zur sucht oder zum
unser verhältnis zum rausch hat sich
insofern verändert als dass wir
bestimmte werte korrektive nicht mehr
besitzen also religiöse werte korrektive
die dazu geführt haben dass wir
wahrscheinlich in der berauschten zeit
die wir je hatten leben ja ich glaube
rauschmittel sind heute viel weiter
verbreitet als je zuvor in der
menschheitsgeschichte
auch wenn immer das behauptet wird dass
rausch immer schon teil der menschheit
war aber ich glaube kulturhistorisch ist
das fast nicht haltbar es gibt keine
keine keine studien die zeigen dass der
der bewusstseinserweiternde genuss
rausch weit verbreitet war das ist das
ist in meinen augen genügt zweck ist ein
anderer ist ein spiritueller mehr
sondern irgendwie man möchte
herunterfahren oder genauer genießt sie
haben sagen wir als gesellschaft heute
müssen radikal umdenken und an anderen
umgang finden mit drogen im allgemeinen
und die konkreten was das cannabis
angeht das kissen plädieren sie für eine
legalisierung oder für eine regulierung
was für eine aufhebung des verbots warum
denn können sie das kurze also erst
einmal wird in der schweiz in europa in
der halben welt wird cannabis konsumiert
auch dort wo es verboten ist
zweitens haben wir eine deutliche
zunahme der der thc konzentration also
der wirkstoff kunst und sie hat ihn
unendlich holt und 4 50 prozent
dabei geht das cbt runter und das haben
wir weil die substanz verboten ist weil
man damit viel geld verdienen kann und
unsere antwort der barkasse kommission
versucht worden wir haben kann diese
woche ein neues papier publiziert zu
diesen fragen uns geht es darum dass wir
einerseits akzeptieren das psychoaktive
substanzen oder cannabis in speziellen
konsumiert wird und dass wir eine
antwort finden müssen wie können wir
konstruktiv den nicht umgehen und
konstruktiv heißt in diesem falle wie
können wir sicherstellen dass sie die
substanzen sauberer angebaut werden dass
die sauber sehen dass die thc
konzentration einen minimalen und
maximalen
nicht über stark dass die vorarbeit und
der substanz gut geht dass wir auch orte
haben wo die sie verkaufen können und
ganz zentral dass wir jugendliche und
kinder schützen können vor diesem konnte
heute können wir das nicht heute haben
wir einen wildwuchs das haus wir haben
kollateralschäden dieses gesetzes und
dieses gesetz erfüllt seinen zweck nicht
gedacht dass heißt sagen sondern man
muss das verbot aufheben um es
kontrollieren zu können um die events
ionen und um regulieren zu können und
prävention auch machen zu können
sie erkennt jemand der die gefahren
wissenschaftlich erforscht verschiedene
drogen und rauschmittel auch von von
cannabis was sind die größten gefahren
beim einkaufen also da muss man zwei
dinge sehr stark auseinander halten und
das jetzt alles dazu legen wird den
rande denn nun wirklich sprengen aber
ganz kurz wir wir wissen dass cannabis
konsumiert bei erwachsenen etwas anders
macht als bei jugendlichen
und tatsächlich hat sich in den letzten
20 jahren gezeigt dass wenn ein
kontrollierter cannabiskonsum bei
erwachsenen da ist das ass oder die die
anzahl der spätfolgen relativ gering ist
so bald wieder eine abstinenz erreicht
wird und cannabis gehört jetzt nicht zu
den suchtmitteln mit dem höchsten
suchtpotenzial das heißt also die gefahr
ins moderat von cannabis abhängig zu
werden
dann habe ich tatsächlich relativ wenig
spätfolgen anders sieht es bei den
beiden jugendlichen aus da gibt es
wirklich sehr überzeugende daten dass
wenn ich während der hirnentwicklung
cannabis konsumieren
im späteren leben bestimmte prozesse
offensichtlich nicht mehr oder gleicher
weise stattfinden das ist zum beispiel
zu intellektuellen einschränkungen
kommen das ist vielleicht so was wie
temperaments veränderungen kommen sogar
eine reduktion des antriebs da ist und
so weiter der jugendschutz wenn ich das
ganz zentral und der muss irgendwie
garantiert werden sie haben das
suchtpotenzial angesprochen das
vergleichsweise gering ist bei bei
nikotin zum beispiel viel viel höher ist
und wir haben eine grafik vorbereitet
die wir uns kurz anschauen
die die verbreitung und das
suchtpotenzial unterschiedlichen
rauschmittel darstellt das scheint
alkohol ist überall präsent 93 der
schweizerinnen und schweizer über 15
haben schon alkohol konsumiert 27
prozent von diesen werden abhängig 85
prozent trinken mehr oder weniger
regelmäßig von den illegalen substanzen
ist cannabis am stärksten verbreitet sei
es als gras haschisch oder öl
jeder dritte schweizer hat schon mal
gekifft 9 prozent von ihnen werden
abhängig kokain geschnupft oder geraucht
haben vier prozent der bevölkerung schon
einmal probiert von diesen werden 17
prozent süchtig was das suchtpotenzial
betrifft steht an oberster stelle
nikotin gefolgt vom opium derivat heroin
1 prozent von herrn und frau schweizer
haben schon einmal heroin konsumiert
ganze 23 prozent der erstkonsumenten
werden süchtig
die partydroge ecstasy haben vier
prozent schon ausprobiert die chance
davon abhängig zu werden ist sehr klein
lsd die stark allogene substanz haben
drei prozent mindestens einmal
konsumiert von diesen entwickeln 5
prozent eine psychische aber keine
körperliche abhängigkeit
ja es gibt natürlich neben den drogen
die der drogensucht ein andere süchte
wie zum beispiel spielsucht und es
widmet sich am 9 mai mit einem
themenabend dem thema sucht es gibt zwei
dog filme und eine sendung einstein dazu
das sollten sie nicht verpassen
jetzt bei ihnen beiden sie haben ja sehr
unterschiedliche haltung zum umgang mit
drogen gesellschaftlich sie kennen aber
dieselben studien dieselben fakten warum
ist denn das so haben sie ein anderes
menschenbild oder ein anderes
verständnis davon was der staat leisten
soll und wo die eigenverantwortung des
einzelnen auf hört ja wahrscheinlich
spielt es eine große rolle
ich bin tatsächlich echter protestanten
es ist ja eine wahl protestanten gewesen
und das hat sicherlich etwas der haltung
zum menschen und zur zur aufgabe des
staates zu tun als wenn man ein eher
paternalistisches bild des staates hat
dann hat man wahrscheinlich auch er die
repressive drogenpolitik im auge also
dass vater staat uns vor uns selbst
schützt genau also beziehungsweise wenn
ich das gefühl habe alles selbst
verantwortung ich aber auch um die
psychologischen schwächen des menschen
weiß nämlich dass selbst verantwortung
durchaus lücken haben kann nur dass
nicht jeder in gleicher weise in der
lage ist selbst verantwortung zu üben
dass dann der staat sozusagen da
einspringen muss und die leute die das
nicht so gut können auch vor sich selbst
schützen muss
herbert empfehlen sie den bundesrat
verantwortungslose maßnahme ich nichts
den 1
also ich bin überzeugt und sagt dass sie
mit klaren
erwachsene menschen brauchen keine
lebensführung besserung ist das heißt
erwachsene menschen brauchen wieder
psychologen sozialarbeiter psychiater
noch ärzte die ihnen sagen was sie
konsumieren dürfen weshalb waren mit wem
sie sex haben dürfen uns auf einen baum
klettern dürfen auf den mount everest
also denn die tiefe springen
das heißt diese verantwortung hilfe
diese freiheit bedeutete braucht
verantwortung und verantwortung in
diesem fall heißt das wir natürlich
wissen was wir tun dass wir als staat
der staat muss hier nur die sicherheit
zu tanzen so sicher zur verfügung
stellen dass der mensch selber
entscheiden kann was er damit machen
kann es gibt dann immer noch nicht das
ist klar
die mit diesen substanzen nicht umgehen
können und da sind wir ein solidarischer
start
da müssen wir die hilfe anbieten damit
diese menschen wieder auf die beine
kommt aber grundsätzlich sind wir
menschen fähig mit psychoaktiven
substanzen umzugehen weil wir lernen
können damit umzugehen
das heißt wir müssen als gesellschaft
den rausch kultivieren aber auch
kontrollieren ein stück weit aber nicht
durch verbote und sie wünschen sich eine
nüchterne gesellschaft naja ich wünsche
mir zunächst mal auch eine aufgeklärte
gesellschaft und wir beide sind ja einer
meinung wenn es zb um die
kriminalisierung des konsums geht
beziehungsweise die entkriminalisierung
des konsums die wir beide für sehr nötig
halten
aber ich glaube das problem ist ein
anderes nämlich dass rausch eben nicht
nur eine individuelle erfahrung ist und
dann das rauschen auch andere personen
betreffen kann und da glaube ich raus
endet sozusagen die freiheit des eigenen
rausches endet auch immer an der
freiheit anderer personen eingeschränkt
werden werden der bekiffte familienvater
abends zu hause sitzt und sich an der
hausarbeit nicht mehr beteiligt dann
betrifft es eben die ehefrau oder die
kinder und so weiter und ich glaube eben
dass wir viel zu sehr von seinem der
individualistischen von seiner eher
selten die wie dualistischen sichtweise
auf den raus inzwischen geprägt sind und
immer wieder ausblenden was es bedeutet
wenn einzelne personen sich herausnehmen
sporadisch oder vor allen dingen
regelmäßig berauscht zu sein was das für
ihr soziales umfeld bedeutet aber bei
ihrer position ist für mich natürlich
unklar wo zieht man die grenzen also
meine kokain kennt man dass es sie
kennen die die gefahren soll man das
auch legalisieren kontrollieren
regulieren und und keine ahnung bis zum
heroin wo ziehen sie die grenze
warum also ich finde wie böse etwas
sehen wir haben einen konsum heute in
unserer gesellschaft und diese konsum
ist unkontrolliert die frage stellt sich
wie können wir diese probleme besser in
den griff bekommen und die frage ist
kann man das bis über verbote oder kann
man das besser über regulierungs
modellen ich finde natürlich auch dann
so wenn man cannabis beginnen weil das
die substanz ist er im heißen konsumiert
wie bei den anderen bin ich auch sehr
sehr vorsichtig und würde auch ein nur
als er sorgfältig aufgebaute forschung
unterstützen frage wieviel rausch unsere
gesellschaft eigentlich verträgt werden
jetzt gleichauf weiter diskutieren auf
dem sofa und sie herr quednau werden
darauf platz nehmen zunächst aber vielen
herzlichen dank in beiden für dieses
gespräch
[Applaus]